we just got huge airpods pro two leaks  let's go ahead and jump into everything  we know and i just gotta say that i am  very excited these news come from ming  chi quo he's saying that they're gonna  launch in the fourth quarter of 2022  now there are a couple things that we  can absolutely expect with the airpods  pro 2 the first being better sound  quality if the airpods 3 sound this good  the airpods pro 2 are gonna sound  amazing the airpods 3 had a big jump in  battery life especially real world  battery life and i think the airpods pro  are also going to get better now quo  also said that there's going to be a new  chip that improves connectivity with  devices so are these finally gonna get  the latest and greatest bluetooth and  are they going to allow you to play  lossless audio quo is saying that they  are going to get rid of these iconic  stems and they're going to go for a  clean look just like the beats fit pro